so second category of
future possibilities in your link have
to do around
our understanding of how the brain and
the mind works
and all of the things that derive from
that so basically we'll
supercharge research going on in
neuroscience today
so first is understanding how the brain
works at the functional level so all the
different modules
from memory to perception to cognition
and all the sub modules of that and
as we untangle those pieces it's
possible
that it will inspire or instruct
us on the engineering side of how to
build smarter and smarter
artificial intelligence systems so
inspire totally new algorithms for
learning systems for reasoning systems
for knowledge base
knowledge acquisition and so on and as
you push that further
of course to me as a artificial
intelligence researcher
the exciting possibility is that we may
be able to understand
human intelligence where not
location wise but functionally where
intelligence arises in the brain
or good answers to the question of what
is intelligence
and the next step is beyond just
engineering ai systems that may help us
understand how we enhance it you have
all these productivity hacks
all these kind of life hacks
understanding
from where our ability to reason about
this world comes from
might help us to really have some nice
brain hacks
uh to improve our ability to reason
in a purely natural way i'm referring to
this is before any kind of augmentation
from a computational device now the next
level of understanding the human brain
as was mentioned by the team as i bring
up often
the fascinating hardest most interesting
problem i would say of the mind
is the hard problem of consciousness
beyond
intelligence where does consciousness
arise from the brain
again not location wise but functionally
and again to be able to with more
scientific rigor answer the question
what is consciousness
is it a property of matter is it a
unique
emergent property of the human brain is
it something totally different that we
don't even understand
like our mind is some kind of key into
an alternate dimension
that uh only psychedelics
and uh a device like neurolink may be
able to unlock
so at the risk of sounding crazy it's an
exciting possibility to take
consciousness from
i would say a field of philosophy in the
20th century
to a field of science and engineering in
a 21st century
to me that's deeply interlinked with
intelligence because i think there's a
beautiful dance there between
consciousness and intelligence and the
human mind
that's not easy or even necessary to
untangle
but i think understanding one will help
us understand the other
and finally perhaps interconnected with
consciousness
and intelligence it might help us take
the question of is there free will
into the realm of science and
engineering versus
the realm of philosophy to try to make a
rigorous study of
where does this experience of uh
making a choice making decisions like
we humans have a control of the way the
future unfolds
from where that arises is that a real
part of the fabric of reality or is that
something that the brain conjures up
what i see neurolink as as i talked with
elon the second time on the podcast
i see it as a way to sort of get beyond
the
the factory walls and see how the inner
workings of the
factories operate as a scientist as an
engineer
and a bit of a philosopher that's truly
exciting
you